time to take control of your credit with
clark county credit union the sponsors
of this next segment rocky spoke to them
about how they can help
we are talking credit reports because
you know this is so important in
everybody's everyday lives but there's
still kind of such a mystery to people
can you explain that
yes there's a mystery to credit reports
because they're mostly unexplored
because of the fair reporting act you
can get a free copy of your credit
report every year from all three credit
bureaus you want to examine those credit
reports to make sure that all the
information is yours and that it is
accurate
and if you find any inaccuracies on your
credit report you can dispute it with
the credit bureaus and get those
resolved
okay and what about a fico score there
are many factors that come into play in
making a fico score so i'll just
highlight some of the main ones how long
you've been in the credit system as one
payment history both good and bad how
many inquiries are on your credit report
every time somebody pulls your credit it
creates an inquiry too many inquiries
can negatively impact your credit score
how much unsecured debt do you have on
your credit report too much unsecured
debt can prevent you from getting a
higher credit score these are just some
of the factors that come into play to
making up a fico score okay it's very
important advice right there but how do
you monitor your credit score and keep
it on track the clark county credit
union our members have the option to
elect bonus checking which comes with
complete identity theft protection and
credit monitoring it's 5.95 a month and
it comes with a lot more services but
i'll just highlight this one so again if
anybody uses your name your social to
try to get credit it's going to pop up
but this doesn't just cover you it
covers every member of your family
living in your household and they don't
even have to be on the account they get
the same coverage as you do including
your minor children and keep in mind the
bad guys would rather get a hold of your
child's social security number than
yours because they can use it for a
longer period of time before it's
detected typically if a minor social is
compromised it's found out when the
child grows up and applies for their
first job or applies for tuition and
then all the damage shows up this is a
way to prevent that from happening see
that is a worthy 595 right there now
what if someone notices an inaccuracy in
their credit report what should they do
then
what they do is they contact the credit
bureaus they fill out their online
dispute form the credit bureaus must
investigate that within 30 days and then
if they verify that that inaccuracy is
in fact inaccurate they have to remove
it from your credit report they also
have to notify you in writing that
they've done so now if they're not going
to remove it let's say it's something
that you found that you don't like and
they're not going to remove it you can
fill out a 100
statement 100 words or less they have to
add that to your credit report so if
somebody in the future is pulling your
credit and they see this negative piece
of information they will also see your
side of the story now is there anything
else that you guys want us to know about
repairing our credit or keeping it on
track
yes as far as repairing credit goes be
very wary of companies that say they can
repair your credit for a fee
there is nothing they can do that you
can't do yourself for free
thank you to clark county credit union
for sponsoring that segment for more
information call
702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.org they have a special offer
sign up for bonus checking today to get
credit monitoring for your whole family